heard this amazing thing that brene  brown said when she came here that for  the next relationship I am in I'm  excited to apply it I'll never forget  her saying this it changed my life she  said I walk in the door and my husband  and I look at each other and we go if  it's out of one to a hundred one being  depleted and nothing to give a hundred  being I've I've got a lot to offer here  and she'll look at him and he'll she'll  go 10 and he'll go 60. and all of a  sudden without her even saying it I'm  like everybody knows where they're at  she doesn't have a lot to give maybe his  cup is running more over than hers he  can contribute if you're to zero maybe  I'm gonna give you some space you know  let you figure it out or be there for  you or if we're both depleted we can  lift each other up or give each other's  face it just seemed like such an  interesting numerical indicator of where  everybody's at in a second and I'm  excited to try it in a next relationship